this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the alabama platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out squarespace
through the link in the description
below more about them in just a bit
you're probably familiar with roman
emperors such as augustus or trajan men
who ascended to the throne and took the
roman empire to new heights you've
probably also heard of rulers such as
nero commodus or caligula the ones who
abused their power and treated rome as a
personal playground where they were free
to satisfy their most depraved vices
these are usually the two groups of
emperors that get the most attention the
ones that sit at opposite ends of the
spectrum but where exactly does domition
fit in if we go strictly by ancient
sources then that's easy he's firmly in
the second camp the one filled with
maniacs and deviants suetonius cassio
dio and tacitus all wrote about demetian
they portrayed him as a vicious paranoid
and power-hungry tyrants but as you're
about to find out many of them also had
personal grudges against him so perhaps
they might not have been paragons of
objectivity when they wrote about him
most historians tend to have a more
lenient view of the emperor they don't
deny his ruthlessness and autocracy but
they think these were mixed in with
efficiency realism practicality and a
genuine desire to improve rome with the
end result being one of the most
contentious and controversial reigns
in the history of the roman empire
[Music]
domitian was born titus flavius
domicianus on october 24 51 a.d part of
the short-lived flavian dynasty that
ruled the roman empire for three decades
during the second half of the first
century his father was vispation a
crucial emperor who brought much needed
stability to roam following the civil
war caused by the year of four emperors
and who may also even have saved the
empire from collapsing just 100 years
into its existence and if you'd like to
learn all about that hot mess we have a
biographics video on vespasian ready for
your viewing pleasure division's mother
was domitila the elder who died some
time before her husband became emperor
he had an older sister named you gisted
dominilla the younger who also died
before her family took power domitian
married once in 71 a.d tim dimitiya
longina the couple had one son together
who died young so let's finish the
family tree with domitian's old brother
titus who ascended to the roman throne
after their father's death it'd be
pretty fair to say that many romans for
space included looked to titus to carry
on the family name to mission grew up in
the shadow of his brother who had
clearly been groomed and trained to take
over the empire one day the spacian even
trusted his eldest son enough to lead
the charge on the first jewish roman war
therefore nobody was really surprised
when titus named the new heir and he
later became emperor by most accounts
titus had a positive start to his reign
even when he was faced with the worst
natural disaster in roman history the
eruption about vesuvius in 79 a.d which
we covered on a geographic video we did
about pompeii if you're interested in
learning more about that however all
hopes of a long successful reign quickly
left when titus fella with a fever and
died suddenly in 81 a.d just two years
after becoming emperor despite the fact
that domitian had previously only held
ceremonial titles and never really had
any actual responsibilities he was now
the emperor of rome there was no love
lost between these two brothers
suetonius accused omission of openly
plotting against his sibling and then
leaving him for dead once titus fell ill
seemingly more concerned with his
ascension to the throne than his
brother's well-being even when the
mission was emperor and titus was dead
and buried the sibling rivalry continued
as the mission bestowed no honor upon
him save that of deification and he
often assailed his memory in ambiguous
phrases both in his speeches and in his
edicts division wasted no time in
becoming drunk with power almost as soon
as he took the throne he gave himself
the modest title of dominious eddu
master and god and made the senate
almost redundant by severely curtailing
their powers the two sides remained at
odds with each other for all of
domitian's reign the emperor made no
secret of the fact that he considered
the senate an obsolete remnant of a
bygone era and that he alone should be
the one making all of the decisions that
would lead rome into a new
and glorious age this is the main reason
why ancient historians were so rough in
their treatment of domitian since many
were senators themselves or were around
in that same social strata sutonia's
contemporary of domitian describes the
emperor as rapacious through need and
cruel through fear while cassius dio
said the division was not only bold and
quick to anger but also treacherous and
secretive and that there was no human
being for whom he felt any genuine
affection but he always pretended to be
fond of the person whom at the moment he
most desired to slay all that being said
suetonius does give credit where it's
due and admits the domitian a very
hands-on approach when it came to ruling
over his empire you might be familiar
with other power mad emperors who
basically treated rome as their personal
piggy bank preferring banquets instead
of budgets and orgies instead of
oversight but it doesn't seem that the
mission fell into that category he
enacted many new laws policies and
edicts and got involved in all aspects
of administration we're not saying they
were necessarily good or improvements
over the previous system we're just
saying that there were a lot of them for
starters domitian fought against
nepotism and did not award many officers
to his family members even though this
was a common occurrence at the time
practiced even by his father vespasian
more than that he opened many political
offices to freedmen and equestrians when
such important positions were typically
reserved only for the senatorial classes
he also ensured that justice was
dispensed with diligence by sitting on
many tribunal hearings targeting jurors
and arbiters who were accused of
accepting bribes it seems that the
suspicious nature and slight paranoia
that usually accompanies a man in his
position of power worked in domitian's
favor because the level of scrutiny he
enacted over his underlings kept
corruption at a minimum even suetonius
had to admit that he took such care to
exercise restraint over the city
officials and the governors of the
provinces that at no time were they more
honest or just whereas after his time we
have seen many of them charged with all
manner of offenses another curious
aspect that goes against the whole mad
emperor persona was the dimension seemed
to be a bit of a prude when it comes to
roman emperors we're used to hearing
about all the weird sex stuff that they
were into but if domitian had a freaky
side he kept it very well hidden
outwardly he clamped down on licentious
behavior and released guidelines for
strict morals he forbade public theater
as well as satire aimed at distinguished
men women he openly condemned
high-ranking officials who were caught
with their pants down both literally and
metaphorically and he enacted capital
punishment on vestal virgins found
guilty of breaking their chastity vows
the only juicy bit of scandal from
domitian's private life comes to us
courtesy of cassius dio who said that
the emperor's wife timitia had an affair
with an actor named paris once domitian
found out he had paris murdered in the
street and intended to put his wife to
death as well until he was talked out of
it by an advisor he and dimitiya became
estranged and the emperor started a new
relationship with a niece named julia
now before we continue with today's
video a quick word from today's
wonderful sponsor squarespace look it's
the age of creation think about it
everyone is out there on the internet
making something we're no longer just
reading blogs or listening to podcasts
or watching youtube we're increasingly
making these things so you've probably
either got a great idea yourself or you
know someone who does and when it's time
to move that project from your head to
the screen in front of you that's where
squarespace comes in is the perfect web
tool to help you fashion the internet
into whatever you want it to be maybe
the hands-on type lots of opinions and
ideas about exactly what your site
should look like great squarespace got
all the customization tools you could
ever want with no technical bs to worry
about or maybe you just need something
functional something that works with
minimal thoughts so you could focus on
your content rather than just the coat
of paint if so good news squarespace has
tons of beautiful templates that you can
use and once you're done setting up your
website there are many extra features on
squarespace so your site can thrive
email campaigns patronage portals social
integrations member only areas analytics
commercial options 24 customer support
everything you could ever want is in one
place so when you're ready to get
started on the next big project of yours
big or small if involves a website you
gotta do it with squarespace go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch your new
site go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics and you'll save ten percent
of your first purchase of a website or a
domain
and now back to it
[Music]
when misha wasn't busy passing laws and
making edicts he was rebuilding rome the
eternal city had seen better days having
suffered one civil war and two major
fires in the previous decades including
the great fire of 64 during nero's time
which destroyed most two-thirds of the
city but this was a costly and
time-consuming endeavor and domitian was
not satisfied with merely making rome
the same way it used to be he had his
own ambitious construction plans to give
it the grandeur that he felt it deserved
for starters he finished two major
building projects started by his father
and brother one was the temple of
vespasian and titus and the other was
the famed coliseum or the flavian
amphitheater as it was called back then
then he renovated some of rome's
greatest structures which had been
damaged in the prior century such as the
circus maximus and the pantheon finally
domitian had his master architect
riberius design a new palace for himself
and build it on top of the palatine hill
a palace of unimaginable opulence and
extravagance that would be the envy of
all of rome he called this architectural
marvel the flavian palace and indeed it
lived up to its reputation so much so
that subsequent emperors continued to
use it as their residence even after the
flavian dynasty was long gone temples
also greatly benefited from demission's
attention as the emperor was a devout
man who regularly offered praise to the
gods particularly minerva the goddess of
wisdom and justice the mission oversaw
the fourth and final reconstruction of
the temple of jupiter optimus maximas
making it bigger and more spectacular
than ever this was the oldest and most
sacred temple in rome but it had a
tendency to get damaged a lot division's
father their spacian had just rebuilt it
for the third time and it only lasted a
few years before burning down again the
mission's renovation seemed to be more
sturdy as the temple lasted for hundreds
of years until the romans turned to
christianity and stopped caring about it
to show his devoutness as well as score
some bonus points with the common people
domitian regularly organized games
fights and races where he presided at
the competitions in half boots clad in a
purple toga in the greek fashion and
wearing upon his head a golden crown
with figures of jupiter juno and minerva
while by his sides at the priest of
jupiter and the college of the flavio
similarly dressed except that their
crowns bore his image as well during
these times domitian awarded the people
gifts of money and threw lavish banquets
because he knew the secret to a long
reign between the people the army and
the senate you needed to keep at least
two of the three happy in order to avoid
being dragged through the streets and
ripped to pieces by an angry mob the
senate was out of the question so the
mission ensured that he never got on the
bad side of the soldiers or the
plebeians
[Music]
if you're going to have a large army of
well-paid soldiers you might as well use
it right well that was domitian's
thinking and he went on the war path
very early in his reign likely since he
considered military glory to be an
essential component of the new and
improved roman empire he was working on
his first target was a germanic tribe
called the shatty although his campaign
didn't really receive the reception that
he was hoping for in 83 a.d domitian
used a very flimsy pretext to declare
war on the chatty and he founded a new
legion called legio iminovia to take the
mod he easily scored some early
victories enough to return home to rome
and justify throwing a military charm in
his own honor but historians of his time
decried his war as uncalled for and a
mock triumph it was very much like the
biggest bullying class beating up the
dorky kid who ate paste and then
bragging about it to all of his friends
tacitus made no secret of the fact that
domitian's actions were motivated by
jealousy of a general named agricola who
was in charge of the roman conquest of
britain and was out there winning some
actual victories while the emperor was
merely play-fighting quote he felt
conscious that all men laughed at his
late mock triumph over germany for which
there had been purchased from traders
people whose dress and hair might be
made to resemble those of captives
whereas now a real and splendid victory
with the destruction of thousands of the
enemy was being celebrated with just
applause it was he thought a very
alarming thing for him that the name of
a subject should be raised above that of
the emperor tacitus was also agricola's
son-in-law so perhaps there's a tiny bit
of bias there but there's no denying the
dominion eventually put a stop to
agricola's career without just cause
recalling him to rome in 85 a.d and then
refusing to give him another military
post even though agricola had been a
successful commander since the time of
vespasian in 87 a.d domitian ended the
campaign in britain altogether
abandoning the caledonian territories
dismantling the fortifications and
moving the roman border further south
his plan soon became evident because the
mission had set his sights on a new
ambitious target the kingdom of dacia as
early as 85 a.d the dacians have begun
conducting raids into moisha their
neighboring roman province the attacks
took on a more threatening nature when
the dacians met the romans in battle and
actually won even killing the governor
of their province opus sabinus in the
process clearly a stronger military
presence was needed to respond to this
threat which is why domitian ordered his
troops from britain to withdraw and
travel to moshe he assumed that five
roman legions led by general kalinius
fuscus would be more than enough to
handle the puny barbarian invaders but
he was wrong because the dacians were
led by their greatest ever commander
king decembales cassius dio certainly
seemed to have more respect for him than
he ever did for domitian and he
described decebalis as shrewd in his
understanding of warfare and shrewd also
in the waging of war he judged well when
to attack and chose the right moment to
retreat he was an expert in ambisares
and a master in pitched battles and he
knew not only how to follow up a victory
well but also how to manage well a
defeat hence he showed himself a worthy
antagonist of the romans for a long time
when fuscus launched his
counter-offensive and drove the dacians
across the border he thought the war was
as good as one to mission had
accompanied him up until that point even
though he remained behind the safety of
the city walls far away from the
battlefield but now he was on his way
back to rome to prepare for his second
triumph when he heard the news fuscus
had crossed the danube river into daesha
and walked right into an ambush the
general was killed one of his legions
was completely annihilated and the
others were forced to retreat it was a
complete humiliation for domitian but
then it got even worse the war continued
for the next few years with neither side
gaining a decisive advantage however it
wasn't like the dacians were rome's only
enemy other tribes such as the markamani
the quadi and the izuki's were all
harassing rome's borders and domitian
simply did not have the soldiers
necessary to deal with all of them in
8880 the emperor had no choice but to
swallow his pride and accept a peace
treaty with decembers which was great
news for daisier because the treaty was
very much in their favor sure desire was
now a client kingdom of rome but the
dacians were laughing all the way to the
bank as they built new fortifications
and equipped their soldiers all with
roman money and engineers provided by
the mission to keep them nice and quiet
the deal worked but both the senate and
the army considered it utterly
disgraceful it wasn't until almost 20
years later that trajan corrected this
black eye to rome when he defeated
desobarlus and conquered dacia
[Music]
although domitian was eventually
successful in stabilizing his borders
again he never truly recovered from the
war with the dacians which resulted in a
humiliating compromise for him even
suetonius someone who gave domitian some
credit in his first years as emperor saw
that the emperor went on a downward
spiral where he steadily gave in to his
paranoia and cruelty the second half of
domitian's 16-year reign was marked by
numerous executions up until that point
he was mainly content to simply neuter
the senate's power and then ignore them
but now he wanted them out of the way
permanently what followed was a purge of
senators ex-consuls governors and other
officials who were executed for the most
trivial reasons domitian put to death
his own cousin flavius sabinus because
he was once accidentally announced by a
crier as emperor-elect instead of consul
while celestius lucillus the governor of
britain was executed simply for naming a
new type of lance after himself the
mission's growing paranoia certainly
wasn't held by the fact that sometimes
people were actually plotting against
him one such event occurred in 89 a.d
when the governor of germania superior
lucius antonio sarternius mounted a
rebellion against the emperor
unfortunately for the upstart agitator
he was surrounded by other generals who
were still loyal to domitian including
the future emperor trajan and they
managed to stamp out the revolt before
it really led anywhere even so it still
presented a convenient opportunity for
domitian to execute some more people
that he accused of being co-conspirators
obviously things couldn't go on like
this forever everyone around a mission
lived in constant fear that they might
be the next one on the chopping block
ultimately a new conspiracy was hatched
although the identities of all
participants remain a mystery a
suetonius tells it the main culprit was
a court steward named stefanus who faked
an arm injury in order to conceal a
dagger within the bandages on september
the 18th 96 a.d stefanus gained a
private audience with domitian under the
pretense of having uncovered a plot to
assassinate the emperor the only tiny
little detail that he forgot to mention
was that he was part of the very plot so
while domitian was reading some
documents stefanus had handed him the
steward pulled out his dagger and
stabbed the emperor right in the crotch
because he'd never heard of the heart or
the neck apparently anyway while this
might have raised mission's singing
voice a few octaves it didn't kill him
so a scuffle ensued between the two men
when other conspirators heard the
commotion they entered the emperor's
chambers and stabbed him seven more
times for good measure and thus came the
end of domitian and with it the end of
the flavian dynasty he left behind a
controversial legacy which could
generously be described as a game of two
halves the first one at least filled
with ambition reform and potential
although ultimately they were replaced
with failure tyranny and bloodshed
reactions to his death were mixed
unsurprisingly the senators were so
overjoyed that they raced to fill the
house where they did not refrain from
assailing the dead emperor with the most
insulting and stinging kind of outcries
the people of rome didn't really seem to
care that much but that cannot be said
for the soldiers who quite liked a
mission they wanted the emperor deified
and his assassins executed which was in
stark contrast to the senate's wishes
who wanted domitian's memory to be
entirely stricken from the history books
obviously the senate didn't get what
they wanted since we are talking about
it right now but without any heirs they
needed to select a mission successor
very carefully in order to avoid a new
civil war and well they chose poorly the
new roman emperor was nerva a former
consul who would serve the empire since
the times of nero don't get us wrong
berber seemed like a decent candidate he
was the first of the so-called five good
emperors he reverted many of domitian's
autocratic policies and sworn never to
execute a senator but nerva was already
in his mid-60s when he took the throne
and as a lifelong bureaucrat he
commanded no respect from the army he
only ruled for a year and a half and in
the middle of his reign the praetorian
guard revolted against him in 97 a.d
took him hostage and forced him to give
up to mission's killers to be executed
once that happened it was clear that any
authority nerva might have once
possessed was completely gone truth be
told his greatest attribute might have
been his ability to admit that he wasn't
the right man for the job which is why
in 98 a.d he willingly and peacefully
transferred power to his adopted heir
who was the right man for the job trajan
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching
[Music]
you